in our series on the new normal we look
at how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives and those
changes affect the way we work the way
we learn socialize and travel and as we
mentioned earlier Twitter announce that
all of its employees will be allowed to
work from home forever if they want to
big change there a new survey from our
partners that LinkedIn found 54 percent
of Americans say that working from home
has boosted their productivity but at
the same time 51 percent said it also
increased feelings of loneliness Dan
Roth is the editor in chief of LinkedIn
and he joins me now dan good morning I
want to get to both of those numbers but
first the increase in productivity I got
to say I'm a little bit skeptical but
54% of people say they're more
productive working from home in what
ways the main one is the is not evening
to have a commute I mean the amount of
time that we lose trying to get to work
and trying to get home from work that is
all time then you can now use answering
emails or trying to get through your
to-do list or even dealing with stuff
around home so people are loving the
fact that they don't have to commute it
doesn't make up for other other issues
so there are lots of problems that come
with this but the fact is they're not
spending time in the car they're not
spending time on the subway and then
they're also not losing time in the
break room now we can talk about whether
that's a good thing or a bad thing but
you're not you don't have your colleague
you know coming over the cubicle wall
and telling you jokes are sending you
the weight of sports scores you really
can just focus on what you need to focus
on yeah well that's definitely true you
don't have the colleague coming over but
you've got your kid coming over or your
dog coming over or the goldfish needs to
be fed or your spouse is in the room or
I just have to get one thing I'll be out
in a second
all of that all those interruptions you
know divide up our ability to pay
attention and and do our work so what
are tips you might have to to keep
people productive
despite this may lay all around them
yeah I mean first of all we we surveyed
professionals that asked him what kind
of interruptions whether they were
having interruptions and what they were
like nearly a third said that they were
have being interrupted by family members
the next step was technology challenges
that we're interrupting them and then it
was pets spouses and
and kids so there are all kinds of
problems that we face at home what we
have heard from members about how they
deal with it are number one they are
trying to make sure that they have a
regimented approach to their day and
that they are talking to their family
about it here's what my day is like here
the hours that I can work I can tell you
that my wife and I have a intricate
schedule for when she is running her
company and when I'm trying to do my job
and when we were homeschooling our three
kids so we try to make it work we go
over the schedules in the morning we
hear a lot of people saying they're
doing that and they are also trying to
make sure that they have a very segment
and on what part of their day is work
and what part of their day is family so
that you can close the computer at some
point and say I'm dumb even though I'm
walking two feet away from where I was
just working I am now in family mode
rather than in work mode yeah yeah
important distinction
all right so putting aside productivity
let's talk about creativity we mentioned
the break room earlier the break room is
actually a place where you might share
an idea get some feedback I mean it can
be a productive moment without that
interaction with a colleague how can you
inspire creativity when you're at home
yeah I mean there are a lot of people
who are being trying to be as creative
as the cam was still having those
unscripted moments with colleagues the
problem is you have to have scripted
unscripted moments and these times of
quarantine so I've heard about people
doing things were for like a half hour
they will get together with colleagues
and they will say where you're gonna
bake something together we're gonna find
a recipe from start to finish that takes
a half hour to do and get your
ingredients ahead of time and then they
just leave their cameras open and they
talk to each other the whole time
they're doing it and you kind of have a
little bit of room for having those
unscripted conversations that's a big
one it still means having to get the
right people in the room you don't have
that experience where someone you know
Stanley walks by and mention something
and you're like oh god I didn't put two
and two together and you come up with
some idea which is where so many of
these ideas come from and I think that
companies are going to struggle with
finding ways to have those bits of
inspiration where just something
connects to people connect in a way they
wouldn't have come together before and
something great comes out of it we are
my guess is in the next couple years
we'll see a lot of people
trying to invent ways to allow us to do
that virtually because right now it's
it's a total challenge very cool and
very good tips my tip here is for
productivity this is the only room in
the house my basement where there's not
a lot of traffic coming in out so
actually take this chair turn it around
and work at the desk right behind me
turning off the monitor that's how I get
things done took me two months to figure
out that little hack but I have it now
Dan Roth thank you very much we
appreciate it you can hear more from Dan
on today's CBS this morning podcast he
discusses thank you very much what new
normal at work with the new normal Murr
at work might look like after the
pandemic there will be an after and he
offers advice to college grads entering
the workforce for the first time